so my name is tracy IV I work here at
the Center for teaching and learning and
I co-direct our national summer
Institute's on scientific teaching I
also work with faculty teaching
initiative and this past semester I had
the pleasure of teaching a course that
was scientific teaching for life
sciences for graduate students and
postdocs so what I want to talk about
today is basically how I piloted I
consider it a huge pilot a tool on the
peer review in canvas okay so just a
little bit of context see that you know
my course I taught BB I co-taught PBS
879 which is again the theory and
practice of scientific teaching for life
sciences the level of this course was
graduate students and postdocs mostly
postdocs about 16 to 4 or so graduate
students but this tool could be used in
any type of class undergraduate etc so
the assignment that my students had word
was to create a diversity statement so a
lot of these postdocs or grad students
will be going out to the job market so
we have a variety of tools in the class
focus on career development and one of
them was creating a diversity statement
so this is the prompt they were given
basically to kind of simulate which they
were applying to a position and they had
to prepare this particular statement so
why did I use the peer review tool well
essentially our students you know Bing
postdocs and graduate students a lot of
them had this season of missing classes
so they had conferences they had a whole
bunch of things so we I think in the
month of April we actually zoomed our
class so that all of our virtual
students could come in because of all of
their many you know obligations and
whatnot and so what I thought was
because we had a two-part session on
diversity statements one being what is a
diversity statement the second being
you're part of a hiring committee how
can we train you to look at criteria to
evaluate the diversity statement and to
actually do that peer review in class I
thought it would be great to be able to
have the students that weren't able to
come to actually still do the peer
review so this was a rationale so there
was a subset of students that were to
complete basic
this assignment online just for you know
hopeful reasons it is a non-credit
course but you they sign up in the apply
to take this course so they're usually
pretty serious about it okay so this is
what I did for peer review so
essentially in our Kansas course site I
created an assignment that was
essentially peer review and I basically
told them you know upload your draft of
your diversity statement and what I did
when I actually went in was I peered
specific students and you can do this in
canvas which is great with other
students so everybody was supposed to in
class have two people review their
statement so I set up the same option on
Kansas for those students who are going
to be virtual as well now a couple of
neat things that I think canvas can do
for peer review is that you can actually
implement a grading rubric inside the
actual peer review feature so I did this
because actually in class we went over
the rubric we went through the hiring
committee based upon the the hiring
committee of a particular institution
out in California so we kind of use that
as a model and I created the criteria
based upon this and it's basically
plugged them into the rubric function
and also added a couple of other areas
there so what the students can do when
their peer review person they're paired
with uploads their particular statement
they can actually see their statement so
it's a nice window view of their
statement as if you have a Microsoft
Word document almost up and then they
also show this particular rubric so they
can actually edit and give comments
directly on the document and they can
also give comments and feedback on the
rubric I was very interested in the
rubric per se because we wanted to say
well would you hire this person based on
their diversity thing although they have
a whole package but would you actually
hire them so they could actually tally
the the items to figure out you know if
they had a high school or not so what
were some benefits so obviously I talked
a little bit about why students were not
in class so how could we still have them
have a similar experience and creating
it outside of class digitally definitely
did this
in some ways for them students can be
assigned as I mentioned specific
partners so you can pair them up you can
also though do this anonymously so you
can actually do anonymous peer reviews
as well depends on your goals what you
desire in the course students can insert
comments directly and so I think that's
also a bonus I don't know if canvas
always had that option but I think it's
pretty neat to actually be able to write
to ten cert on the document itself and I
can uh you can upload rubrics or
criteria in any form or fashion okay so
there were a few challenges that I'd
like to also Express - this is my first
time using the tool and in the class so
students I realized some of them they
needed to kind of know how to use the
tool so I probably should have in the
beginning showed a few of them how
before they left and what else into
other places but I think I just needed a
little give a little bit more structure
there one of the students was abroad and
didn't have the proper software I don't
know why I'd have desks like they can't
see at another point but we just said
you know when you come back to the
United States just you know do within
that's perfectly fine but some of the
stuff or whatever happened was
incompatible and if the peer reviewers
partner didn't upload their assignment
obviously they can't start so I think
it's a good idea if you use the tool to
you know definitely set deadlines we did
that encourage the students to actually
upload so they're not always waiting for
their peer reviewer to come up the nice
thing that happens is on the canvas site
you can see who's your peer who you're
going to peer review if you don't do it
anonymously as well and then they can
you know kind of see if that person has
uploaded their files as well so that's
essentially what you know I did for
uploading the peer review tool I'd like
to do it again and there may be a larger
scale I think there was only about five
or six students that actually use it in
ours on our complete class but overall I
think it was you know it was valuable
for them they still feel like they were
part of the class even though they
weren't physically present and they were
still able to do this process as well I
imagine that you can also do it you know
if you want to have students do it
outside of class right so just because
you know you don't want to do the peer
review in the class you could use this
tool as well as an option so that you
don't have to devote the actual class
time to it so that's that so I love
taking questions
yes and that's a nice thing too yes I
can actually see everything that they
wrote so that's that's great because I
can use it you know in my we didn't
grade the actual assignment itself but I
can actually go in and I can actually
could actually grade it and how they
well they did their peer review and I
could actually comment upon it too as
well so I think it's a really nice
feature so you can comment directly in
the document and then the rubric is kind
of on the side as well so you can kind
of see like I can when I go and I can
actually see this is what scores they
got on the actual rubric which is not
showing right now but and then what but
where do they insert comments or you
know suggestions and actual documents
and that's on the scientist einman to
appear things yes a word dog on the
actual assignments yeah so if you do any
other type of assignment is it it's
pretty much like that yeah yeah yes
pretty much can you think she goes okay
oh that's looking it probably I'm
assuming can Teaching Fellows I assess
those canvassing can Teaching Fellows
view your entire course right so if
you're rapidly exact same access as you
and professor they'll be able to see
that where are you guys are there any
plans if you have undergraduate graders
or learning assistants we do have a role
specifically for greater and I'm happy
to talk about that later on if you must
contact me good question
the the actual functions in canvas so
they couldn't lost in to canvas but
again they were abroad so I don't know
the computer access and we thought it
would be too complicated to you know so
I told him to come back but it was the
functions in canvas so I have no idea
you know why okay uh-huh yeah I think
that was his major issue he couldn't
open the actual file in canvas so we
couldn't see the partners of a document
any other thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you